Hi, I'm Finnur and I work on the Google Chrome
extension system.
I'd like to tell you how to debug extensions
for Google Chrome.
Extensions in Google Chrome are just like
web pages that you can debug using the built-in
tools of Google Chrome.
Let me show you how it works:
In this folder, I have a simple extension
I wrote, called "Email this page" that allows
you to send the current web page address as
an email.
It also contains a bug, which we'll track
down, together.
I’ll start by loading the extension. One
option is to use a command line argument but
we'll use the Extensions Management UI page.
The management page shows that no extensions
are currently loaded so I’ll expand this
section to get to the developer tools and
click on Load Unpacked Extension.
Then, I'll specify the extension and load
it.
Notice that our extension shows up in the
list and a new icon has been added to the
toolbar representing the extension.
When I click on the button, nothing happens.
In the details section for the extension,
there is a list of active views.
I ‘ll click on the name of the active view,
in this case background.html, to inspect the
background page of the extension.
This brings up Google Chrome’s developer
tools, showing the code for the extension.
I am now going to switch to the Scripts view
and put a breakpoint where we receive the
mouse click event from the user.
If I try the extension again, I'll break into
the JavaScript debugger.
With the panel on the right, I can watch certain
expressions, look at the call stack and check
what values the variables contain.
Now I am going to use F10 to step over this
line and F11 to step into this function, until
I get to console.log statement.
This statement will output debug information
to the console window.
I am now going to clear it.
When I execute this line we'll see the console
message.
And if you look closely at the current line,
you'll see that I misspelled the variable
name url.
There’s our bug!
If I press F10 again, we’ll see an error
in red and execution stops.
Let me go ahead and fix this.
I'll use this opportunity to show that you
can also use alerts, even from background
pages.
Now, let’s switch back to the Management
UI page and reload the extension.
When I click the button, I get our alert and
the extension works as expected.
For views that are not active such as pop
ups and options pages, I can load the page
directly and inspect it.
For example, my extension contains options.html.
If I copy the extension ID, type in chrome-extensions://<paste
the id>/options.html I can inspect this page.
I can even change the in-memory style sheet
on the fly.
When you do this, just make sure to also update
the style sheet on disk, because if you reload
the page, the style sheet changes will be
discarded.
And that's the basics of debugging extensions.
To find out more about Google Chrome’s developer
tools visit www.chromium.org/devtools.
For more information on extensions check out
our website at code.google.com/chrome/extensions